Bitte schön.
Mein Name ist Dr. Keser.
Guten Abend Herr Herr Doktor.
Ich bin Mutter auf diesem Kanal,
Dienstabend bei Arzttätik.
Freut mich sehr.
Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Herr Doktor, vielen Dank für Ihre Zeit.
Ich bin heute extra zu Ihnen gekommen,
weil ich mir jetzt ein Fall überlege,
was ich heute anbieten kann.
Darf ich Ihre Namen erfahren?
Ja, mein Name ist Herr Ulrich Geiger.
Geiger.
Können Sie bitte Ihre Vorname und Nachname bestellen?
Ulrich ist mein Vorname.
Mein Name ist Udo Ludwig, Richard Ida, Cesar Heinrich, Ulrich.
Mein Nachname ist Geiger, Gustav Emil Ida, Gustav Emil Richard.
Gustav Emil Ida.
Und dann Gustav Emil Richard.
Geiger.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 62 Jahre alt.
26.
Wann sind Sie geworden?
Ich bin Gebräufe am 3. Mai 1960.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin circa 1,74 m und ich wiege 95 kg.
Herr Kilom, bitte nochmal.
95.
Danke Ihnen.
Was für eine Welchwertung haben Sie?
Ich habe seit mehreren Wochen schon Schmerz in den Oberbau.
Und jetzt seit 2, 3 Tagen habe ich immer wieder so Husten
und ein saures Aufstoß hin.
Und manchmal ist der Husten so stark, dass ich auch erbrechen muss.
Seit wann haben Sie Husten?
Seit einer Woche ungefähr.
Ist der sogenannte Bauchschmerzen,
das ist gleichzeitig aufgetreten?
Also die Bauchschmerzen, die habe ich schon seit mehreren Wochen schon.
Das ist im Oberbau, aber wie gesagt, der Husten ist erst seit einer Woche.
Und Übelkeit auch.
Können Sie bitte Ihr Bauchschmerzen beschreiben?
Das passiert oft nach dem Essen.
Dass ich ein bisschen Übelkeit habe,
dass dann auch ein bisschen Schmerzen im Oberbau auftreten.
Und ja, das sind manchmal Krämpfe, aber oft sind es eher so Schmerzen.
Ist das dauerhaft oder altabend?
Das ist unterschiedlich. Es gibt Phasen, da ist es relativ stark.
Aber dann gibt es auch wieder Phasen, da ist es etwas weniger.
Wenn es am Tagszeit, zum Beispiel, ich tag diese Schmerzen auf einer Skala,
nur zum Beispiel keine Schmerzen,
und die sind sehr unverträgliche Schmerzen,
können diese Schmerzen auf welche Stücke einzuschätzen?
Also wenn die Schmerzen sehr stark sind, dann würde ich sagen,
ist es so bei fünf oder zum Beispiel sechs.
Und dann muss ich auch Schmerzmedikamente nehmen, das wird danach besser.
Aber wenn ich weniger Schmerzen habe, dann ist es vielleicht so zwei oder drei.
Welche Medikamente gehen die diese an?
Ich nehme Nevalginen.
Welche Dosenen?
Ich glaube, das sind Filme von 100 Milligramm.
Und manchmal nehme ich sogar gleich zwei Stücke.
Bei Bedarf nur?
Bei Bedarf, ja.
Ist ihnen gehofft?
Das hilft mir schon, aber das hilft immer noch ganz wenig,
nur für ein paar Stunden.
Komm.
Wie ist dir Ihre Kustin, zum Beispiel,
dieser Kustin mit Ausruf?
Nein, das ist eher ein Trockenhausen.
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass ich so ein Reis oder ein Kratzchen im Hals habe.
Und dann muss ich leicht husten.
Und wenn ich anfange zu husten, dann wird es manchmal mehr.
Und das hört dann nicht mehr auf.
Aber oft ist es so ein Kratzen im Hals, was sehr unangenehm ist.
Gibt es bestimmte Auslöse?
Andere ich jetzt nicht, nein.
Das kommt immer wieder mal.
Nach dem Essen kommt es verstärkt vor.
Wenn Sie sich flaschen, lege ich abends mich zum Schlaf hin.
Dann wird es auch etwas mehr.
Das stimmt.
Gibt es bestimmte Unverkehrlichkeiten gegen die Telefon?
Nein, mein Appetit ist eigentlich ganz gut.
Ich habe auch Hunger, aber ich habe jetzt keine Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten.
Ich kann so ziemlich eigentlich alles essen.
Das sind bestimmte Probleme, zum Beispiel mit dem Salat oder Sturm?
Nein, da habe ich ja gut mit dem Wasser lassen.
Ich habe auch die Stuhlgangs-Kammer, die ich jetzt als alter Mann mitgegeben habe.
Da muss ich öfter auf die Toilette.
Mein Urologer sagt, es kommt wegen der Prostata, aber da nehme ich auch eine Tablette.
Aber ansonsten Stuhlgang und so weiter ist eigentlich glücklich herweise bisher alles in Ordnung.
Welche Toplite gegen eine Prostata?
Das hat einen kompletten Namen.
Das nennt sich Tamsu oder so ähnlich.
Tamsu 0,4 glaube ich.
0,4?
0,4.
Kann ich aber nach...
Kann ich nachher noch mal in meine Liste nachgucken.
Danke.
Herr Karja,
Sieht man Ihnen so wie ein Tischmarsch, zum Beispiel,
ich trage dann die irgendwelche Körperregeln aus, zum Beispiel Rücken oder Unterbauch?
Nein, also das ist mehr im Magengegend.
Aber manchmal strahlt es auch ein bisschen in den Bauch raus, aber ansonsten nicht.
Haben Sie früher eine Erndische Beschwerden gehabt?
Nein, wie gesagt, das ist erst in Zeit einigen Wochen.
Früher habe ich so etwas noch nie gehabt.
Ich hatte früher mal einen Herzinfarkt und habe einen hohen Blutdruck.
Aber so mit den Magen hatte ich bisher eigentlich nur nie Probleme.
Das war vor 10 Jahren.
Ja.
Sind bei Ihnen eine Stand oder ein Gerüpfelopération angesetzt oder gehört?
Ja, als ich den Herzinfarkt hatte, da hat man einen Herzkartetal gemacht.
Und ich habe damals auch zwei Stands bekommen.
Aber seitdem bin ich immer in regelmäßiger Kontrolle beim Herzarzt, also beim Kardiologen.
Und er sagt, das ist alles in Ordnung.
Ich nehme meine Meditamente.
Und ich hatte seitdem bisher nie Probleme gehabt.
Welche Medikamente für diese Erklankungen?
Ich nehme das Asperin 100.
Ich habe Ramipril, 5 Milligramm gegen den Blutdruck.
Und ich nehme Methaprolol 47,5.
7?
47,5.
Zum Beispiel gegen eine Cholesterin?
Ach so, das stimmt.
Ja, Cholesterin nehme ich auch.
Das nennt sich, glaube ich, Atobastatin, 10 Milligramm.
Nehmen Sie diese Medikamente regelmäßig rein, oder?
Ja, natürlich.
Die nehme ich jeden Tag ein Jahr.
Achtig drauf.
Das war sehr gut.
Und keine irgendwelche Erschweden.
Ich habe auch ein Gehirn von Herzkrankheiten, oder?
Nein, vom Herzen habe ich bis zu nichts gehabt, war alles in Ordnung.
Das war sehr gut.
Im Vorgeschichte der Krankheit, oder die Operation vorgeschichte,
gibt es noch sonstige Operationen oder sonstige
perspektive Krankheiten oder chronische Krankheiten?
Nein, da habe ich jetzt,
Operationen habe ich jetzt nicht.
Ich war einmal, wie gesagt, gegen meine Brust,
ganz kurz bei dem Krankenhaus,
aber das war dann alles in Ordnung.
Keine Operation?
Nein, keine Operation.
Aber Operationen habe ich keine bisher nachher.
Herr Kollege, rauchen Sie?
Nein.
Im Vorgeschichte zum Beispiel,
haben Sie schon etwas geraucht?
Ja, ganz, ganz wenig.
Es war ein sehr junger Mann,
weil wir haben die Arbeit, aber eigentlich rauch ich nicht.
Wie viele Jahre alt war ich?
Wie viele?
Ich war für ein, zwei Jahre, aber nicht lange.
Ich glaube, ich war 30 Jahre alt.
30 Jahre alt?
Nein, ich war 30 Jahre alt,
und ich habe nur für ein Jahr oder so geraucht.
Also, wie viele Jahre alt war ich?
Das war so eine halbe Schacht, glaube ich.
Halbe Schacht.
Zuerst Alkohol?
Bitte?
Alkohol, ja.
Ich trinke ab und zu mal ein Glas Wein.
Und manchmal auch ein Bier.
Ein Flasche Bier.
Und jeden Tag?
Oh, nee, aber so jeden zweiten, dritten Tag trinke ich gerne ein Bier, ja.
Zum Amtessen.
Oder manchmal Wein.
Und manchmal Wein, ja.
Herr Kajer, sind Sie gegen, was Sie gerinnt?
Übrigens, gegen, übergen Infektionkrankheiten und...
Also, mein Hausarzt sagt, meine Impfungen sind alle komplett.
Auch gegen Boranay Info?
Ja, ja, ich habe, bin auch schon geboostert.
Und das hat mein Hausarzt alles komplett gemacht.
Geimpft?
Gut, sehr gut.
In der letzten Zeit, sind Sie zum Beispiel,
ihr getroffen oder mange Stöcke gereicht?
Nein.
Ich habe eine Frage über Kampeln.
Mit Gliedern.
Herr Kajer, hier Eltern...
Sie sind beide schon gestorben, ja.
Meine Eltern sind beide schon tot.
Nicht leid.
Ja, die Eltern...
mit Wäschermaltern gestorben und...
Ja, mein Vater war circa 80 Jahre alt.
Er hat einen Herzinfarkt gehabt.
Und meine Mutter war 72.
Sie hat einen Schlaganfall.
Ja, Vater ist ein Herzinfarkt gestorben.
Ja, ja.
Er war in Wäschermaltern gestorben.
Er war circa 85.
Er ist glüben, kann ich gut verstehen.
85?
Ja, 85.
Danke.
Herr Schüweste?
Nein.
Bruder?
Nein, ich bin ein Einzelkind.
Ihre Großeltern, oder die irgendwelche...
meine Familienmitglieder oder Verbandschaft?
Ja gut, ich habe einen Cousin.
Meine Großeltern leben auch nicht mehr.
Aber ich habe nur einen Cousin.
Zum Beispiel Superkrankheiten.
Soweit ich weiß, hat er keine Krankheiten.
Ich glaube, da hat man einen hohen Blutdruck, sonst dabei nichts.
Herr Kajer, was ist mit dem
Schreiner?
Ich bin Schreiner gewesen.
Schreiner, ja.
Wie ist dir Familienstand?
Ich bin alleine, meine Frau ist auch vor fünf Jahren gestorben.
Aber Sie können den?
Ja, ich habe zwei Söhne.
Sind Sie gesund?
Meine Kinder sind gesund, glücklicherweise.
Haben Sie Stress?
Nein, ich bin in Rente, ich habe keinen Stress.
Nein?
Wie war das für Ihr Beruf?
Der war stressig, das stimmt.
Ich habe ein eigenes Geschäft gehabt.
Aber seit ich in Rente bin, ist alles viel besser geworden.
Herr Kajer, ich bin fünftig mit dem Alhambrail sehr.
Vielen Dank.
Haben Sie noch etwas fragen?
Ja, ich frage mich, ist es der Magel?
Das macht mir Sorgen und diese Husten ergibt mich auch.
Ich würde mich freuen, wenn Sie herausfinden, woher das kommt
und was man dagegen machen kann.
Herr Kajer, ich weiß nicht, wie schnell Sie etwas haben.
Aber ich muss erst mal sagen, dass wir körperliche Unterhörungen
von Ihnen abnehmen, um sicherliche Diagnose zu stellen.
Wenn Sie eine Verfahrung haben,
dann müssen Sie etwas geben.
Vielen Dank.
Ich habe Zeit, aber das ist kein Problem.
Sehr gut.
Dann machen wir die Übergabe an den Oberarzt.
Danach können wir die Diagnosen besprechen.
Wir erhalten jeder Ergebnis vom Untersuchen.
Wenn ich Ihnen Bescheid gebe,
dann gebe ich Ihnen Bescheid.
Vielen Dank für Ihre Mühe und Zeit.
Sehr gut.
Jetzt machen wir die Übergabe an den Oberarzt.
Guten Tag, Herr Oberarzt.
Guten Tag, Herr Dr.
Ich möchte Ihnen eine neue Portion vorstellen.
Natürlich.
Herr Ulrich, Herr Kajer,
so ein 60-Jähriger Patient,
der eine Wetter-74-Ros- und 95-Jähriger war schwer.
Er kam mit einer episodischen und vor einem Wochen persistierenden Bauchschmerzen
und er hat mit dem Begleitenden eine Portion geholfen.
Er hat die Schmerzen kollegartig und nachdemessen aufgetreten.
Er hat die Interstate 5 oder 6 Bauchschmerzen.
Auch seitdem wird der Patient, der die Schmerzen hat,
keine Strahlen aus.
Auch die vegetative Anemnese ist auf trockenen Kosten
und sogenannte Bauchschmerzen.
Wo sind die Bauchschmerzen? Unter Bauch, Oberbauch, der Pegastral?
Die epigastrische Bauchschmerzen, ich habe gesagt.
Es gibt keine Beschwerden.
An der Vorurkrankung sind beide Patienten,
die 10 Jahre eine Herzkatheter durchgeführt haben.
Diesmal wurde bei den Patienten zwei Ständen eingelegt.
Er leidet an eine Antiprostatische Medikament.
Er hat vor zehn Jahren einen Herzkatheter bekommen.
Er hat eine KHK.
Er hat beide Patienten keine Allergie bekannt.
Er nimmt eine Antiprostatische Medikament und 4 Milligramm.
Er nimmt eine Herzkatheter mit 300 Milligramm und 4 Milligramm.
Er nimmt eine Herzkatheter mit 47,5 Milligramm mit 1 Milligramm.
Er hat beide Patienten eine Herzkatheter mit 80,5 Milligramm.
Er hat beide Patienten mit 72 Jahren gestorben.
Er ist gesund.
Er ist ein Schreiner.
Er hat zwei Zöhne.